they're pleading guilty et's obtained
Laurie and her fashion designer
husband's plea agreements signed
yesterday just 12 days after a federal
judge refused to dismiss all charges
they face for paying half a million
dollars to get their daughters into USC
by having them pose as crew recruits
the prosecution's case was very strong
it really wasn't looking good for them
that they were convicted
they were looking at years in prison if
the deals approved YouTube star Olivia
Jade and sister Isabella who both
dropped out of USC will see their dad
and full house star mom go to the big
house for months she's facing two months
in prison 150 thousand dollar fine two
years of supervised release at a hundred
hours of community service Massimo is
gonna be facing it an even bigger
sentence five months in prison a two
hundred and fifty thousand dollar fine
and two hundred and fifty hours of
community service now it was more of the
spearhead of this while Lori seemed to
be more of an active participant a
source tells ET Laurie is scared the
fact that she will do time is crushing
for her but now some wonder if she and
her husband could be using the current
pandemic to their advantage like another
famous defendant hot pockets heiress
Michelle Janus had her prison sentence
delayed due to cope at 19 and is asking
to serve her time at home I don't think
that this judge is going to allow Laurie
Lachlan or Massimo Jun le an opportunity
here because they decided to plead
guilty during a pandemic this judge has
been keen that he wants the second
example and that these parents need to
go to jail
the couple's hearing is tomorrow via
live videoconference
each was facing 45 years behind bars
this is really an amazing deal for them
[Music]